we're on in Columbus Ohio as you know
sure and here is the way the station
that has us in Columbus Ohio chose to o
promote this interview today at UMich
football Homer at Rich Eisen talks with
at coach Jim for um listen live at 2:00
p.m. Eastern gave the link did they put
the M in or do they do the red X no I
put the M's and everything they put the
and Emin that's nice of them yeah coach
Jim Harbaugh joins me here on the Rich
Eisen show how are you coach I'm good
rich should I should I be have a problem
with the way that that the Columbus
station promoted this interview coach I
have a problem with that I I didn't
catch that it's it they said today at
UMich football home or at Richards and
talk to the ACT coach Jim for um is that
accurate do you think what do you think
um if you have a problem that I don't
think you should have probably little
now publish these good publicity
I know why you would have a problem with
it they spelled my name right your
Twitter handle to you know and the the
program's Twitter handle so I shouldn't
have a problem with it right I could
just continue on with this interview
start off like I can't speak for you but
I don't see where you would have a
problem okay
so how many how many how many frequent
flyer miles do you have coach are you in
the seven figures what do you think um I
don't know exactly
mm-hmm because if you because you've
you've been all over the map you've been
all over the globe how did you how did
dope how did you like the Italian trip
where you took the kids to Italy did you
get out of that what you were hoping to
get out of taking the team there to
Italy yeah all and more it was an
incredible trip the best thing I've ever
been a part of on a football team the
wonderful thing was it was really it was
all about the players and their
experience not all learning is done in
the classroom that all learning is done
on football field and from an
educational standpoint from a team
bonding standpoint experience it
had everything was spiritual it was it
was it was it was football it was
teamwork it was enlightening on a lot of
levels so what did they learn I mean
what in particular can you pinpoint say
that they these kids are and the team's
better off for having done that in Italy
well it starts with seeing things you've
never seen before
tasting food you've never tasted before
hearing a language that you've never
heard imagined seeing a the Colosseum
there was active events there for 600
years building the Pantheon that was
built 80 years after the death of Christ
2,000 years old and then here in some of
the guys talking like wow that's that
buildings 450 years old and the
McDonald's down the street is been there
since 1972 we thought that was a
landmark so so many so many things and
to experience yourself and then
experience through others on your team
that's that's what makes a group trip so
wonderful why eighth graders go to
Washington DC why senior class trips in
high school go sometimes to Rome it's
not just your own experience it's
everybody else that's on the trip as
well and how they're seeing it and what
their reaction to it is and then even
when you come home people ask you about
it and then you know things that didn't
know before it's that's why it's so so
enlightening in so many levels Jim
Harbaugh joining me here on the Rich
Eisen show did you need to get an
advance team to find out the pontiff's
shoe size prior to presenting him with
the kicks that you presented him coach
we did Sarah Harbaugh did that on wife I
think she she did find out the pontiff's
shoe size can we share that can we share
that yeah size size 9 but got got a size
10
uh-uh Pope Francis wears orthotics so I
had to be a little bit bigger huh I had
no idea amazing Wow okay lighting at so
many levels can I mean did is that good
think of it did you follow it it's of
course are you kidding me I saw you
drinking from the trevi fountain um
although that did you you made a wish
even though that's not technically what
you're supposed to do in that fountain
correct my eight-year-old daughter told
me you're not supposed to say what your
wish is okay but and then and then one
thing I'm really proud of that after the
trip was over 25 to 30 of our players
did study abroad did internships about
25 to 28 did study abroad then another
five did European internships and then
another 10 or so travelled during Europe
our guys had options in the month of May
they could do those those things they
could come home and do spring term at
the University of Michigan they could go
home to their homes they could do
internships in the United States
football players had options which is
long not been the case and throughout
the entire month whether they were
abroad or whether they were here
studying or back home we didn't have any
incidences no no shenanigans no
kerfuffles no incidences of any kind and
anybody that knows 18 to 22 year old
effect it's quite remarkable and
something that we're very proud of Jim
Harbaugh joining me here on the Rich
Eisen show I was doing my best to pay
attention what was going on in Italy but
at the same time I was sitting on a set
in Philadelphia for the NFL Draft
hearing the University of Michigan one
after another after another get
mentioned it was a record number of
Wolverines for the Wolverines drafted in
the draft what do you think that means
for the program as you are trying to
continue to build it coach
well first and foremost what a great
example so many of our players set the
way they prepared themselves the three
to four years that they were here at the
University of Michigan to put themselves
in position to play at the highest level
we like that a lot and it's a great
example set for our younger players and
incoming players that there's a template
there of how you how you go about
developing player development and the
the youngsters that accomplished it the
eleven that were drafted and then the
other eight that were signed to free
agent contracts they carried the
material majority of the water I mean
it's it's their accomplice but it does
set a great example for our younger
players well one of the moments you
perhaps were missing it because you were
handing the pontiff some orthotics was
lived as my favorite moment coaches and
I made them I made them in the NFL
Network truck ree-ree show it the live
shot of Browns fans celebrating Jabril
peppers being drafted to the state of
Ohio and one or two of them it looked
like we're wearing Buckeyes gear they
were high five and they were fired up I
loved it you missed it they should be
yeah at the they got a outstanding
football player mm-hmm very explosive
very fast and the he loves football
that's they're gonna I think they're
already seeing somebody's just head down
working and to make his team better
hungry to make his team better than this
that's who he is it's that's what
they're the torts are getting fans are
fickle though don't you think when it
comes down to it coach right one minute
they are I may love them generalize that
way yes a nice let's just generalized
well just Ohio we're here at Michigan
the just Ohio offense from our alumni is
most always been supportive a few more
minutes with the coach of the University
of Michigan football when was the last
time you spoke to Colin Kaepernick coach
we've talked okay and how is he handling
what is happening with him
not having a gig as most OTAs are
wrapping up this week well talk to him
yet about a four hour workout last time
we talked it was a talked a little
before the workout Lenny we talked after
his workout it was about a four and a
half to five hour workout so that's how
he's handling he's preparing himself and
getting ready to play football it's it's
what he wants to do it's what he loves
to do and how his handler is preparing
himself two to four for the season do
you think he is a starting quarterback
in this league still and why do you
think other teams might think otherwise
coach I do believe that yes is still in
his 20s
and he'd been very successful at the NFL
level as a starting quarterback and I'm
on record well-documented I think he
will will win championships before his
careers is finished what what did you
find about him that you were able to
connect with him in a way that it seems
like so few other coaches have been able
to unlock what what he did on the field
Jim the ultimate competitor very
talented because tremendous effort it'll
be the first one in the building he'll
be the last to leave and the one thing
you can't count on calendar because he
tells the truth never ever heard him lie
to me or anybody else and a couple more
minutes left with the coach University
of Michigan for those who are looking at
the number of players that you just
mentioned left 19 as you said to go to
the National Football League what
challenges are you facing to replace
those kids right there on the campus as
you get ready for Florida for opening
weekend coach yeah it's it's you can
look at part of the depth chart I mean
maybe five or six maybe seven guys that
are returning his starter so a lot of
the depth chart has been been been wiped
clean at the first string level so that
has created a
lot of competition it's created
opportunities for the fellows that have
been sitting behind a guy for a year or
two years and now their opportunity is
to be the full-time starter and ensure
what they can do and so the waters are
hot in that regard and that's a it's
been a fun team to be coaching and been
working since the winter winter
conditioning spring ball now we're into
summer conditioning and we've got a
young team and we have some some good
returning starters as well and some key
positions which is good but it's a young
and talented team and it's our job to
coach them in and get it ready and and
their job to get themselves prepared to
to carry the load but it's much better
than having a young and untalented T
that would be the that would be the
worst possible what do you think of the
Friday nights being on the schedule for
Big Ten football coach idea I am NOT for
it at all I think Friday night is for
high school football and what what can
be made of this is there any way to
reverse course do you think for this
well I think there's a way that I think
there's a way that that'll happened
sometimes the pendulum swing swings one
way and do something that's not
productive for the game of football and
then it has the ability to swing back
the other way I don't know that that is
set in stone nor should it be and I
think the voice the opposition of
playing high college football games on
Friday night should be should be voiced
last 140 coach are you still continuing
the honorary captain program and if so
who shall dare to step into the same
shoes I wore last year coach well this
is going to be some good ones we're
putting that together now well I'll
announce who that that list is but
people of your of your stature which
okay we're striving for well you know if
you need me to help in any way shape or
form get folks ready for it or
give them the the idea of how to conduct
themselves and have a successful weekend
I'm available for you to have those
folks contact coach okay and I would not
have we're not hesitate to have them
contact you you set an example at the
very highest level thank you very much
coach thanks for calling in take care
stay out of your family and everybody in
Ann Arbor for me always a pleasure
talking to rich thank you you got it
that's Jim Harbaugh the Rich Eisen show
weekdays at noon eastern on radio
stations across the country and audience
if you like that video be sure to
download our apps don't have any memory
on your phone let's start to delete some
of those slo-mo videos you have and you
know which ones I'm talking about